today on the matt walsh show two teen
girls in dc carjack and murder a man and
it's all caught on video
this is part of a far-reaching cultural
trend it's time we look honestly at the
problem or
it's gonna get a lot worse plus five
headlines including biden's plan to
require
vaccine passports and dr fauci says that
children
should still wear masks when they're
even when they're with each other when
they're playing with each other they
still have to wear masks he says also
a tick-tock teacher speaks out against
the racism
of light-colored band-aids in our daily
cancellation we will deal with what i
consider to be
the worst yet most common marriage
advice all of that and much more today
on the matt walsh show
well the footage is significantly worse
than the george floyd video
to my mind though it has attracted
barely a fraction of the attention and
the outrage
mohammed anwar was a 66 year old
pakistani immigrant in dc he was killed
this past tuesday
while delivering food for uber eats two
black teenage girls ages 13 and 15
attacked anwar with a taser while
carjacking him as he tried desperately
to reclaim his property
which he needed you know he needed his
car to do his job and provide for his
family
um the girl sped away with anwar
partially hanging out of the vehicle
they flipped the car in the escape
attempt a few blocks down sending anwar
careening several feet away and he died
cell phone video shows the victims
splayed out on the ground
mangled and bleeding while national
guardsmen who
of course are in the city as you've
heard pull the murderers out of the
wreck
and the primary concern for both of
those girls is that their phones may
have been damaged they're they're
running around
screaming about their phones while this
man is dead
nobody at the scene on the video anyway
to include the guardsmen
show any apparent concern for the dead
man on the sidewalk
this crime is part of a growing trend in
dc over the weekend
two 13 year old boys were arrested for
multiple armed carjackings in the city
a few days before that and a few days
after anwar's death a different pair of
teenage boys 13 and 14 this time were
also arrested and charged for an armed
carjacking
for those keeping track at home that
makes what six kids
all under the age of 16 arrested for
violent carjackings in the same city in
the same week
the mayor of dc fortunately has the
situation under control on sunday she
tweeted out a psa video
recommending strategies quote to reduce
the risk of your vehicle becoming a
target
with an accompanying protect your auto
hashtag
now this of course is no different than
a mayor responding to a string of rapes
in the city by putting out a video
recommending that women wear longer
skirts now feminists are quick to remind
us that
rape is the result not of provocative
fashion choices by the victims
but of evil actions by the rapist
himself
in the case of anwar's death the tragedy
was caused not by his failure to protect
his auto which he tried to protect it
but by the behavior of two teenage girls
who have
managed to become murderous psychopaths
before either of them is old enough to
you know buy a ticket to a raider r
movie
the question we're afraid to ask but
must ask
is how do kids turn into this how do
they turn into monsters
like this take a couple steps further
back
widen the lens and it's clear that the
trend extends beyond a carjacking
epidemic in dc
you know you could draw a line that
connects this incident
to for example the the equally tragic
case of e lee
in milwaukee a few months ago miss lee
an asian woman
was lounging alone in a local park when
a group of black teens happened to cross
her
and they decided to um physically and
sexually assault her
apparently just for fun before dragging
her to a nearby pond
and leaving her for dead one of the
teens charged in her murder khmer lewis
age 17 explained that he didn't really
care if she lived or died because quote
because quote he didn't know her
personally
now a few weeks ago in rochester two
black teens aged 14 and 16 broke into 53
year old steven amenhiser's house
doused him in some kind of lighter fluid
might have been gasoline
and set him on fire he died a few days
later in the hospital disfigured and in
agony
with burns over 70 of his body within a
few days of that crime
a white middle-aged girl in a virginia
suburb was gunned down by a black teen
lucia bremer
13 years old was walking through the
neighborhood with a friend at 4
30 in the afternoon in the suburbs when
she was approached by the gunman and
fatally shot
no motive has yet been given we're told
by the family by the way that
lucia was supposed to help with the
neighborhood easter egg hunt
this weekend the racial dynamics of
these crimes
make them politically inconvenient for
the media which is why you haven't heard
very much about them
indeed the crimes defy all of the usual
talking points and standard explanations
there isn't even a potential gun control
angle on any of them except the last
one victim was burned to death another
tortured raped and beaten another killed
by
teen girls wielding a taser in a stolen
car
these crimes cannot be pinned on racism
at least not the brand of racism that
the media prefers to talk about
and they can't be used to push the kind
of policies the left favors
so our strategy then as a culture is to
look away
pretend it's not happening i really
think the image of the crowd
stepping around anwar's broken body and
not not even
looking at him is a tragic metaphor
because this is the strategy that our
whole society has adopted to these kinds
of things
still these kinds of things are
happening and frequently
young kids often not yet at an age where
they can obtain a learner's permit
are committing unthinkable acts of
brutality against totally innocent
people who
pose no threat to them now whenever
there's a mass shooting of random
victims in a school or some other public
place
we generally will turn our attach
attention to it and we'll engage in
serious conversation and debate about
what can be done to stop the bloodshed
but these smaller scale acts of casual
sadism
are much more common and widespread
they happen literally every day in our
cities
many more people are killed many more
communities are terrorized
you know during trump's administration
his critics were fond of responding to
whatever he did or tweeted by saying
this isn't normal this isn't normal
well i wish the same could be said of a
13 year old murdering a man for his car
i wish i could say this isn't normal but
it is
it's normal the murder rate in most
major cities attest to that it is normal
but it shouldn't be now it's not
difficult to identify
some of the factors that have made these
kinds of things normal it can be assumed
without even checking we can assume
right now and i'm willing to say right
now my guess without looking
is that most or all of the kids involved
in the crimes that i just listed have
been raised in homes without fathers
we we know that right off the bat
this is the case for the majority of
black children especially in the city
and it's increasingly the case for
children of all races as unwed
parenthood becomes
more and more common compounding the
problem many kids
spend their days marinating in the
nihilistic filth produced by
half-literate sociopaths like cardi b
the rapper lil nas x made waves this
past week when he released a music video
which shows him sliding down to hell
on a stripper pole and giving a lap
dance to satan
the video was accompanied by the release
of his new quote satan
shoes which feature a pentagram and
actual human blood
in the shoe will nazex who cultivated a
large fan base of children with his
first hit
old country road or rather old old town
road i think it was called
which itself was vapid brain numbing
garbage and i said as much if you may
remember on this show when that song was
popular
anybody got a lot of children fans
because of that because of that dumb
awful song and now he's trying
desperately to shock us with a stick
that was
that well you know really wasn't even
all that shocking when marilyn manson
did it 25 years ago
now the only difference is that marilyn
manson never pretended to be an artist
for kids
this guy this dirt bag did
so he had a whole lot of kids
subscribing to his youtube channel
and then without warning he drops the
video of him giving a lap dance to satan
a bunch of nine-year-olds watch that
this weekend without their parents
knowing
still the content itself only fails to
shock us
because we're so accustomed to living in
a culture where putrid
toxic sludge is pumped out of hollywood
and the music industry and directly into
our children's minds
this is the situation that many millions
of kids find themselves in
they have no moral guidance at home
they consume immediate diet of non-stop
perversity and degeneracy they live
lives that are 90
online conditioned to see other humans
as disembodied avatars on a screen
there's no beauty in their lives no
truth no goodness no joy no love that's
a
that's another prediction i can make
about all those kids
we talked about earlier how can we be
surprised
when they only when they turn into
killers and criminals
what else would they become what else
would you expect
it's only going to get worse from here
unless we set about to make
massive massive cultural changes
but to do that would require us to
confront the problem honestly
from the start that's the first step
and we don't have the courage to take it
now let's get to our five headlines
you know it's so great to have a company
out there that uh
is on our side in the culture the
company that that has
morals because there are so few of them
and that when you when you find one you
gotta
you gotta you gotta hold on to it for
dear life and certainly support a
company like that
and it's easy to do with charity mobile
because charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to pro-life pro
family charities
of your choice um and this is really
important because the right to life is
the key that
unlocks all other rights the
foundational right if you don't have the
right to life you don't have a right to
anything else
now through april 16th new activations
get a free cell phone after instant
credit plus
free activation free shipping and a free
pro-life key chain
that's why i said it's easy to support
this company because not only is it a
great cause but it's a great service on
top of it so it's a win-win-win
situation
no contracts no termination fees no risk
with a 30-day guarantee
what that means is you got nothing to
lose when you support this company when
you try them out you're not going to
lose anything they're not going to
hook you into a contract or anything
like that you try out the service and
you're going to love it trust me
and all the while you're helping to
build a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life
phone company so throw out whatever your
your your company is now throw them out
and go with charity mobile you won't
regret it
call charity mobile at 1-877-474-3662 or
chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
you know i felt kind of bad i was at um
well i don't know if it felt bad is
really that
is really true but we were i was out
with my wife and uh my
brother and sister-in-law in in
nashville this past
weekend on friday we were at the
distillery in midtown which is a great
place they got
not a big cocktail guy but they got good
cocktails cocktails there so
a quick recommendation if you're ever in
nashville anyway uh
we're sitting there waiting for our
table and the you know woman comes up
she's a fan
and uh she says to me you know i love
your podcast
and she says uh i know you hate people
but i just wanted to tell you that i
love your podcast
and everyone else at the table thought
it was hilarious and they started
laughing hysterically
um and then i responded you know and and
and i said uh i said no i don't hate
people i just really dislike them
which of course at that point my wife
and she always does this because
she's like my translator that's why i
need her in social situations because uh
she of course stepped in and said he's
joking he's joking which is what she
always says when i
do that kind of thing in public but i
thought about and i realized that that's
probably
85 of the time when someone approaches
me in public they begin
with with that that's almost always i
didn't laugh because that's what i
expect that was that's like the opening
line for almost everyone i know you hate
me i
hate people i know you don't like people
but and then they because like they have
to open with an apology for talking to
me and then they continue
and i thought maybe i'm coming off a
little too harsh
if everyone feels the need to say that
and i had a moment of self-reflection
and then i said no probably not it's
fine and continue to be about my day
um and it's it's kind of nice because
mostly what people will do
if i see them in public is they'll just
kind of give the head nod
which i i kind of prefer that even if i
if i know you don't know you that that's
my move anyway even for people that i
know
if i see them just the quick head nod
like acknowledgement and then we all
we just keep moving all right um number
one from the daily wire
the biden administration is reportedly
working on developing coronavirus
vaccine passports
that would allow americans to prove that
they've been vaccinated
since um some business businesses have
indicated that they will require proof
of vaccination for people to enter the
businesses
washington post reported quote the
administration's initiative has been
driven largely by arms of the department
of health and human services including
an office devoted to health information
technology
the white house this month took on a
bigger role coordinating government
agencies involved in the work
the report said that a digital version
of vaccine passport would be available
through smartphone apps
and could display a scannable code
similar to an airline
boarding pass well no big deal there you
just
you need the equivalent of a boarding
pass
that that's what we're going to hit
that's where we're heading as a society
you need the equivalent of a boarding
pass to
walk into a restaurant or really do any
go into a store
um the vaccine passports are expected to
face significant hurdles quote unquote
surrounding data privacy and making sure
that the passwords cannot be
counterfeited
well i would hope i would hope that they
would face hurdles um
beyond beyond those the post added quote
one of the most significant hurdles
facing federal officials the sheer
number of passport initiatives underway
with the buy administration this month
identifying at least
17. those initiatives such as world
health organization led global effort
and a digital pass device by ibm that's
being tested in new york state
are rapidly moving forward even as the
white house deliberates about how best
to track the shots and avoid the
perception
of government mandates of a government
mandate to be vaccinated
and that's i said that months ago i
believe i did
or if i didn't say it i thought it and
should have said it that
people are worried about it yeah a
mandate people are worried have been
worried that the government's gonna say
you have to get this shot if you don't
get it you're gonna
be fined or have to go to jail or
something
they're not going to mandate it they're
going to do an end run
around the mandate by simply making it
so that
you can't do anything you can't live
your life unless you get the vaccine
but then that always allows them is
there a lot of
civil civil liberty problems with a
a national federal vaccine mandate
so they're going to get around that by
making it so that you can't do anything
and then they can always say what do you
mean there's not a mandate i'm not we're
not
forcing you to get the vaccine sure you
can't leave your house or do anything if
you don't get it but
you're still free not to get it
that's how they can get around it but
the real irony here is
that we get this news right on the heels
of renewed panic over
voter id laws right we had that
the law that passed in um in georgia
which for the most part really basic
minimal level
kind of putting putting a few
systems in place to make sure that
people who are voting are you know
legitimate residents of the state and so
on
really basic stuff but even that we're
told is
to require someone to do something
really simple
like have a photo id when they go vote
simply to prove that they are who they
say they are and that they are a
resident of the state in which they are
voting
we're told that that is racist somehow
um and it's a it is a a burden
an undue burden to have to produce an id
i mean think about how often you vote
at most once every two years we're
talking presidential elections once
every four years
so it is a it is a a cruel undue
burden to tell someone that look if you
want to vote in 2024 in the presidential
election
you've got four years to figure out how
to get some kind of photo id
lice anything just some kind of photo id
you have four years to do it
that's a problem but requiring a vaccine
passport
every day to potentially do anything to
participate in society forget about
participating in the quote democratic
process
to participate in society generally
that's that's fine
there's no problem there
of course yet another uh yet another
double standard of many okay number two
i have to play this from cnn our friend
uh
brian stelter there there are speaking
of irony there are so many levels of
irony here that um i think it's worth
playing
and uh here it is let's watch you may
have noticed something
about the former president i don't know
what it is
either it's an unwillingness or an
inability to leave the spotlight
but it's been on full display this week
actually five times
uh president trump making appearances on
fox news newsmax and
on a fox personalities podcast here is
we just we wanted to summarize it all in
in one sound bite so here it is
here's a summary of what trump said
about the biden administration
they're destroying our country to
destroy our country
they're destroying our country they're
destroying our country lisa
they're destroying our country lisa
right it's like he was singing a song
but really off-key
he's saying the same thing on every show
and he was back on fox last night
visiting with janine pirro now let's
contrast trump with the last
one-term president the last guy who was
defeated after a single term that is
george h.w bush do you want to see what
bush was doing
after losing re-election this is what he
was doing
oh looks great doesn't it looks so
relaxing
bush told his successor bill clinton
quote you're not going to have any
trouble
from me and he kept his word now trump
is the anti-bush of course
but to borrow a fishing metaphor here is
the media taking his bait
does this feel like 2015 all over again
with outrageous statements
stoking days of news coverage is the
is the media am i taking his bait right
now am i currently doing the thing that
i'm criticizing
what do you think guys yeah i'd say so
so we got two things there number one
uh yet again this thing the media does
now where they
they are romanticizing first it was it
was first it was george w bush and now
george h.w
bush romanticizing the bushes
i mean for for years we were told that
these are war criminals and scumbags and
horrible people but now
i remember remember the bushes those
were good people
you know why can we get a republican
like that again like the people i
accused of i accused of war crimes
uh but also what's funny is that
those those whatever was four or five
media hits that
that donald trump apparently did i
didn't even know
about any of those until i watched that
clip from brian selter
i might have i might have heard of one
of them and i'm in conservative media
so stellar saying that trump can't get
off the stage well you're
no you're putting him on the stage
donald trump doing an interview on fox
news that's not really being that's
he's that that's that that's that's one
thing
he was accessing the conservative
audience
no no big surprise there but you're the
one putting him on the larger stage by
by giving his his message access to an
audience that wouldn't hear it on fox
so no it's it's not that that stelter
and cnn it's not that they're worried
that trump won't get off the stage it's
that they
desperately need him to be on the stage
and they're going to drag him onto the
stage if he does step off of it
because they need him he's the only
thing they know how to talk about
they've been conditioned that way for
the past five years that's all they've
got
and yeah they've kind of moved on to on
cnn
it seems like 80 percent of their
programming now is complaining about
tucker carlson
so they they kind of they've replaced
trump a little bit with with someone
else
but they still they can't quit trump
they just can't quit him they need him
brian stelter most of all all right
number three dr
fauci was on face the nation and uh the
question to him was about
specifically kids and masking and and
what we should be requiring our kids to
do
here's what dr fauci said so if parents
are vaccinated
they still do need to be concerned about
their unvaccinated children
playing together in groups is that right
yeah the children can clearly wind up
getting infected when we talk about what
you can do when you're vaccinated
you can certainly have members of a
family if the adults are vaccinated
and you're in the home with your child
you don't need to wear a mask and you
can have physical contact
when the children go out into the
community you want them to continue to
wear masks
when they're interacting with groups
from multiple households
oh that's good but don't complain he did
give you permission to
uh have physical interaction with your
own child
so he said that if your kids at home
the kids at home fauci will allow you to
uh to have interaction with them and
they don't even have to wear a mask so
that's that's very generous of fouchy
isn't it that he's giving you that
permission
in your own home that people are still
listening to this guy people are still
hanging even a year
into this when he's changed his mind on
a million things
says a different thing every day people
are still hanging on to his to his every
word
letting letting him guide their
day-to-day
life when he was never
qualified for that to begin with
even if he was the greatest guy in the
world and the most honest guy in the
world which i don't believe he is
but he's still he's an immunologist
that's that's where he if he has any
expertise that's where it would be
in terms of advice on how to live your
life generally
balancing all these different things
balancing the risk of a virus versus the
risk of
locking a kid in their home for a year
taking away the friends education
everything he has nothing to say on that
whatsoever
he's not an expert on that never was
there's absolutely no reason to listen
to him on that
the only thing he can allegedly tell us
is what sort of activity is more likely
to spread virus and what's relatively
isn't but
how do you balance that in the grand
scheme
he was never an expert on that
should have never pretended to be he
should have been clear about that from
the beginning
if he was really an honest guy he would
have been he would have said listen
this is what i do i can tell you about
the virus but in terms of how you live
your life
and what you do with your kids and
whether they go to school and all that
stuff
whether they see their friends what they
wear when they see their friends i can't
tell you about that those are decisions
you have to make on your own
an honest and humble man that's what he
would that's what that's what such a man
would have said but of course he's not
that kind of man
no if you're if you're still look if um
if you need to take your kid into a
store or something
or you need to get on a plane like you
really need to and you have to get them
on the plane too because you got to go
somewhere
um and you put your kid in the mask mask
because because you have to
like i i get that part of it
um if it's absolutely necessary
now the plain part like they're they're
gonna kick you off the plane if
two and over so they if you have a two
and a half year old they're gonna tell
you
that the two and a half year old has to
be in a mask
so for me i'm just we're not getting on
a plane until that madness stops and if
it never stops we'll never get on a
plane as a family again
because i'm not doing that you know we
have a kid who's almost two she's not
gonna be in a mask
but if you have to be in a certain
situation and the rule is that you gotta
put the kid in the mask then i
understand
that you gotta do what you gotta do but
if you're still choosing
in a in a voluntary situation to put
your kid in a mask i don't know what to
say to you
like you're getting together for a
playdate or something at a playground
and you've got your little four and
five-year-olds in masks
no one is forcing you to but you do it
and i've seen this kind of thing at
playgrounds
you're you're like you're a lunatic is
what you are and you're harming your
child
you're doing psychological damage to
your child because of your own fear and
paranoia
to make yourself feel better nothing's
not for your kid be clear about that
you're doing this for you and you're
hurting your kid knock it off
you maniac
all right number four here's an article
from fox5ny
about a new survey on internet usage
none of this is terribly shocking but i
still think we should look at these
numbers
we see these surveys that come out every
once in a while uh just so we can see we
can see how bad it is
so the survey says researchers found 31
of respondents in the survey admit to
constant internet use another constant
as in
basically never stopping throughout the
day every almost almost every waking
moment they're online
another 48 said they log in several
times a day and just six percent said
they limit their online activity to
about once a day
since 2015 near constant internet usage
among people
ages 30 to 49 has risen by 14 points
and for people between 50 and 64 it's
grown from 12 to 22 percent
researchers have noticed the percentages
of near constant users between 18 to 29
years old
has remained 48 since 2019
and people older than 65 are stagnant at
eight percent well that's half
18 to 20. and again constant is exactly
what it sounds like all the time
it's you know when i read these surveys
it i can't really judge
because i'm i'm very close to the
constant category
though i always have the excuse that it
is actually my job
and i do get paid for it but even so
um and this is the kind of thing we
talked about at the beginning
you know this is absolutely one of the
factors
when we talk about what is what's
turning kids into violent sociopaths
why is this happening
uh this this is one of them yeah it's
it's lack of parental guidance at home
it's pop culture it's you know all these
are factors that
that go into it um and a big part of
that is when you got kids and this is
how a lot of kids are raised now
and it's going to get worse if they
don't have parental guidance they don't
have a dad in the home
they don't have a mom that's very
present um
maybe the mom's on drugs or something
which is often the case so they get like
no guidance at all and so all they have
is their phone they've got the internet
and um and that's what they do all day
and think about that from it can be hard
for us those of us who at least
had a little bit of a childhood before
the internet took over
for me there's a very distinct moment i
could i think it was about maybe about
the age of like
13 14 when the internet
it's it seemed looking back on it it
seems almost like an all
like like an all at once thing or before
that the internet existed and yeah i
had i can remember being nine years old
and i had a friend down the street who
had the internet i think had aol 1.0 and
i didn't really understand what it was
exactly and
i used it once and i wasn't that
interested um and then a few years later
it took over and everybody had the
internet but so
so in people my generation we had a
childhood where this kind of stuff
basically didn't exist or certainly
wasn't ubiquitous
um but kids now don't have that they
never had a childhood without it
so what do you think's gonna happen to a
kid every second of the day
this is what they're doing of course
it's gonna have a desensitizing
effect when you're conditioned to
interact with people like in this way
not really interacting with them as
human beings but as as
images on a screen
it all plays a part and it all
contributes to it
and that's why i say massive cultural
changes
part of that part of that massive change
is a is a move away from this trying to
raise kids
in a way that allows them to have an
authentic
human childhood that involves things
like
going outside running around the woods
going out and playing dodgeball or
something
it's all part of it okay number five um
this has become the standard
the traditional time i guess for me to
play crazy tick-tock videos
and i know i know you people like it
don't don't claim that you don't
this is for your own good and here's
today's installment let's take a look
white privilege
think about it whose flesh tone is this
i have brown band-aids in my classroom i
had to special order them
they're twice as much as these and
they're hard to find
and they're frequently out of stock but
when i hand a brown child
a white band-aid i am literally adding
insult to injury and i refuse to do that
in my classroom
she's a hero speaking out against the
scourge of light-colored band-aids
now if we really have to engage in this
conversation which i guess we don't but
i'm choosing to
i'm choosing to waste my own time and
yours you're welcome
uh the the first thing is that there is
of course
a logical explanation for for why there
would be
more band-aids in that in that color
than in the darker colors because that
skin color is
more common and so they're going to be
more of them out there in the
marketplace
really makes a lot of sense when you
think about it
but also in my experience with first of
all kids love band-aids
i don't i don't i don't quite understand
it even though i was a kid once and i
could remember having a band-aid
fixation myself
i still can't figure out quite what it
is kids love band-aids
um they're always trying to invent
reasons why they need a band-aid
you as when you're a parent you
constantly have kids coming up to you i
got to cut i have where's your cut let
me see and they show you
like some that's on their finger and you
look at it nope that's there's no i see
nothing there
they insist that there's a cut so you
put the band-aid on and and magically
makes everything better
but kids love band-aid and what they
prefer in my experience
are band-aids that don't that don't
match their skin color they want bright
colored band-aids they want a batman
band
they want a scooby-doo band-aid
what what message does she think is sent
when you give a kid a scooby-doo
band-aid
are you making them feel how does she
think that works i don't know
but you know you know you know you're
getting desperate you know the white
privilege
narrative is uh falling apart when you
have to look to
the colors of band-aids to prove your
point
when you're reduced to that i think that
tells you that white privilege really
not much of a problem in this country
let's move on to reading the youtube
comments this is from kyle stewart
he says birds are not neat pets they're
filthy it's almost like owning
ferrets people can tell that you own
ferrets just by
jogging past your house the set the
smell is unmistakable yeah that is true
that's just
birds if someone had recommended last
week i guess a bird as a pet
if i don't like cats and dogs but yeah
birds seem like they smell even worse
and they're noisier like we covered and
on top of it they're even
they're even more useless than a cat or
a dog
like a bird is not gonna do anything for
you at all a cat could at least kill a
mouse
maybe a dog can bring you the slippers
maybe he's gonna chew him up and slobber
on him too but he can try
what's a bird gonna do for you um
let's see av reacting to the video of
the woman screaming at uh people who
don't wear masks and claiming that
workers and hospitals are exhausted av
says that lady is nuts
uh i work in hospitals we aren't
exhausted maybe tired but that's because
we work 10 to 12 hour shifts to begin
with
if anything we have less people to take
care of i've
i've heard that a lot all along for the
past year i've heard that from many
hospital workers
rachel says matt i think you're wrong
about the age limit policy
even at 90 years old thomas sol is a
sal sol arguably has one of the sharpest
soundest minds i've ever heard
instead we need to have campaigns um
that can't hide candidates in a basement
and the media can't run cover to achieve
their agenda
policies yeah i've got a lot of comments
and we talked about
an age limit for the presidency and i
think it should be 75
to run you know that's that's the oldest
you could be i think that's pretty
generic because that gives you 40 years
right 35 to 75. you have 40 years to run
for president don't do it in that time
then go retire and sit on your on your
porch with a rocking chair in the
rocking chair with your grandkids sounds
like a great plan
much better way by the way to spend your
final years than as president
um in a much more respectable way too
in my view and i got a lot of these
kinds of messages and comments from
people you know
saying well no we don't need an age
limit because here's this random older
person who's doing really well at the
age of 90.
uh whether it's a prominent person or
you know oftentimes i'll hear oh my
grandmother
you say that but you don't know my
grandmother she was sharp as a tag until
she died in 93.
i i get it but first of all even at
if you're saying that a 90 year old is
sharp as attack
what you mean is for a 90 year old
but there's still the reality of being
90 and you're gonna have
a lot of physical decline a lot and even
mental decline
your mind is not going to be as sharp
and spry
and aware and able to process things as
it was at
50. it's just a simple fact there's no
way around it we are mortal creatures
you can't get around it
so that's what you mean that's the
qualifier you mean all of that 490
he's doing pretty good which is great
but still
and also these are the exceptions right
but
when you're when you're setting a
general rule or policy
you can't do it based on the exceptions
again 35 is the lower limit right and
there there there are some 31 year olds
out there who maybe
would make fine presidents not a lot of
them but
they probably exist you probably find a
31 year old
who would make a good president but
they're the exception
and so we have the limit at 35 and no
one complains about that
so a you know an 82 year old who could
handle being president
handle it physically and mentally and
not
lose their mind in a process or die in
the process they are
a rare exception and when you're making
policies you
you can't take into you can't make a
policy
based on rare exceptions
um and finally nicholas says hey matt
talking about my my idea for competency
test for voting
says hey matt say your company
competency test is put into effect if a
12 year old aces the test
would you allow that child to vote um
that wouldn't be ideal to me but that is
a deal that i would make so
that's a compromise that i would be
willing if we could talk about this and
if we came to that
uh compromise i i would be fine with
that it's not my ideal
right because i think that there should
be on top of a competency test for
voting there should be other
requirements too
and another requirement is i think we
should actually raise the voting age
probably to 25
and then put other requirements in place
as well
but if we could only do one thing then
i'd say fine you know what
let's have the really basic competency
test for voting
and all that's going to establish is
that you have like even a third grader's
level of of knowledge when it comes to
civics and
government and all of that and politics
and i'd be fine with that so let's just
say anyone who could pass that test can
vote
and so if you're if you're 56 and you
can't pass it you don't vote
if you're seven and you can pass it then
you can vote
i would take that deal now a quick word
from rock otto
you know it's it's springtime the
weather's getting nice well it wasn't so
nice
in nashville here this past weekend we
got like 50 feet of rain i think was the
last check
but normally weather's nice and what
that means is that you want to get out
of the house and
and you know just be doing anything
other than sitting in or standing around
an auto parts store
why waste your time doing that
rockauto.com makes a lot easier
when you have access to rockauto.com at
your desk in your pocket you go
to rockauto.com find everything you're
looking for rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much um for the
same parts or even
twice as much for a worse selection but
you might not even find the same parts
you can find on rockauto.com
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog is really easy
to navigate
and you can very quickly find everything
you're looking for and again it's going
to be the cheapest it's going to be the
the best price you're going to find
anywhere so go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available
for your car truck and write walsh in
there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you you know
as you've probably heard
candace joined the daily wire a few
weeks ago with the premiere of her new
talk show candice
um you may have heard us mention that a
time or two the show streams friday at 9
00 pm eastern 8 pm central and offers a
stimulating perspective on politics
culture in america at large candace
hosts a series of guests on the show
each week
making for lively panel discussions and
insightful interviews feature guests
have included
uh jocko willink brandon tatum john rich
just to name a few
i mean and you know i think probably the
headline here is that i'm going to be a
guest on candace
pretty soon so you know that should be
in this copy i don't know why it isn't
candace is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live audience but
don't worry if you can't attend the show
in person tweet your questions to at the
candice show for a chance to have
candace answer your question at the end
of the night
and make sure to become a daily wire
member go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code canvas to get 25 off
that's code candice for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
for the daily cancellation we're going
to step away from matters of politics
and ideology so that i can put my
relationship expert hat on that's
actually mine putting a hat on so you
understand
i'm not really a relationship expert but
but then i don't think it's really
possible for anyone to be that kind of
expert so i have as much claim to the
title as anybody else
so today i want to deal with and cancel
of course what i believe is perhaps the
worst marriage advice
you will ever hear and precisely what
makes it the worst
is that you will hear it and you have
heard it a million times already
it's very commonly believed and commonly
said even by people whose own
personal experience contradicts the
advice
they're dispensing the advice i refer to
is this
never go to bed angry never go to bed
angry
like i said you've heard it a million
times right what brings it up right now
is a new study
making the rounds online which purports
to lend scientific credibility to this
awful piece of
faux wisdom here's the article from
psychology today it says
when people resolve when people resolve
interpersonal arguments before winding
down their day and going to bed
it can break the vicious cycle of
festering negative emotions perpetuating
chronic stress along this line new
research
from oregon state university suggests
that the daily habit of resolving an
argument before day's end
can curb the emotional toll of everyday
stress triggered by interpersonal
conflicts
in ways that might have lifelong
benefits over time the osu researchers
speculate that
getting in the habit of resolving
arguments by day's end
may reduce chronic stress and promote
living a longer healthier life
everyone experiences stress in their
daily lives you aren't going to stop
stressful things from happening
the senior author of the study noted but
the extent to which you can tie them off
bring them to an end and resolve them is
definitely going to pay dividends in
terms of your well-being
resolving your arguments is quite
important for maintaining well-being in
daily life
in other words don't go to bed angry and
this is not the first study that has
claimed to confirm this age-old advice
another one was done in 2016
and there according to the guardian the
lead researcher also concludes
quote we would suggest to first resolve
arguments before going to bed
don't sleep on your anger now this is
all fantastically wrong in fact
the best thing you can do with your
anger in a marriage is sleep on it
this is the practical reality most of
the time no matter what the studies say
now it's true that if you can simply
snap your fingers
and make yourself not angry and your
spouse not angry before putting your
head on the pillow
that would be ideal and if you can
snap your fingers and forgive and snap
your fingers and make your spouse
forgive
again that would be best but experience
suggests
that you can't always curtail your
emotions with the snap of your fingers
and you certainly can't curtail your
spouse's emotions by snapping your
fingers
trust me i've tried hey stop being angry
snap out of it often this will have the
opposite of the effect that you intend
i have found what this means is that
when you're actually in this situation
okay you're in the thick of it you're in
an argument with your spouse the clock
is ticked
past 9 p.m you're both angry you're both
frustrated
you have two choices assuming the
snapping fingers trick didn't work
you can either keep hammering it out
into the until the the wee hours of the
morning
going around and around in circles
refusing to go to sleep or allow your
spouse to sleep until you feel
that the issue has been resolved or you
can simply go to bed
and let your emotions settle and see how
you feel in the morning
if you choose the latter course what
will almost certainly happen is that
when you wake up in the morning you will
realize
that you were overreacting and you'll be
grateful that you went to bed rather
than saying all of the things
you wanted to say in the moment if you
choose the former course that is you
decide to
take all this bad advice and stay awake
until you reach resolution
what will almost certainly happen is
that the fight will escalate into the
night
as you both get more tired and more
annoyed until finally it
ends not so much on a resolution but
just on a note of sheer exhaustion
then you'll still have to go to bed like
you could have done four hours ago
and you wake up in the morning way more
tired perhaps still annoyed because
you're tired
and rather than thanking god that you
didn't say all that you wanted to say
instead wishing to god that you hadn't
said all that you did say
i don't care what the study results say
or what facebook meme cliches say
this is how it works in real life see in
a marriage
there are like fight levels almost like
a video game okay
level one is the standard brief
snippy little exchange that you might
have with each other over some extremely
unimportant thing maybe you're
you know you're looking for the lost tv
remote and you're both accusing the
other
of being the last one to have it even
though it was always one of the kids
that lost it
um and maybe someone left the milk out
on the counter you know
maybe and this is a totally random
example maybe your wife keeps putting
the pancake syrup in the fridge when it
clearly belongs in the pantry and you
exchange words over that like i said
random example
the thing about a level one is that it's
stupid and all you have to do in order
to resolve it is
realize how stupid it is and move on or
better yet laugh at yourselves
that's the best way to end an argument
really is by laughing and it can be done
all you have to realize is how dumb this
is
but then the fight the fights work their
way up right in gradations
until you get to level six which is a
fight where one or both of you are
threatening divorce
now it is possible and very much advised
to try to go your whole marriage without
ever having a level six
i mean we've made it 10 years and
counting without a level six so
that's what i would advise there
somewhere in between level one and level
six around levels three and four
that's where you start making statements
that begin with phrases like
you always and oh yeah well you remember
that time
three christmases ago when you this is
when you're dredging up old offenses
you're reopening old wounds
taking one offense the other has
committed and claiming that it's a
chronic problem
they always do it giving specific
examples of other times when they've
done it showing that you've been holding
a silent grudge all this time
this is the danger zone it's where you
go from irritated to
deeply angry it's where the shouting
starts
so here's my point the longer you drag
an argument out
especially at night especially when
you're tired after a long day of work or
a long day dealing with the kids
the more likely it is that you will work
your way up through these levels
so don't worry about resolving your
level 2 dispute at 10 30 the best
resolution is simply to stop talking and
go to bed
trying to resolve it only means that
you'll be at a level 3 before you know
it and who knows where it goes from
there
i'm not saying that you should avoid
confrontation at all costs in the
marriage i'm not saying that you know
there's never a time when you really
need to hash something out but the idea
the very popular idea that every
conflict every argument
must reach a mutually satisfactory
conclusion before either of you can go
to bed is lunacy
it's a recipe for sleep deprivation and
lots of arguments that get a hell of a
lot more emotional and intense than they
ever needed to be
i mean if you want a level one milk on
the counter dispute to have a chance at
becoming a level six
i'm moving out and taking the kids with
me situation then the best way to make
that happen is to keep the argument
going well into
the night angry and tired is a brutal
combination
it's a recipe that can cook up all kinds
of dishes
that you'll you'll regret eating in the
morning trust me
one other note you'll often hear uh
that uh don't go to bed angry is
biblical supposedly this horrifically
misguided
stupid advice can be found in scripture
thankfully that's not really the case
the verse that people usually cite is
ephesians 4 26
and i've even heard you know pastors use
this in sermons and
and with this exact advice and um
and what but what that verse says is in
your anger do not sin
do not let the sun go down on your anger
now if you want to take that in the most
literal possible way
then you must take it to mean that you
should resolve every argument not before
bed
but resolve it before sundown and this
might be a real problem
because if one or both of you was at
work you might not see each other until
30 minutes before sundown
so you better get to arguing right away
before the witching hour
maybe you could do it over dinner in
front of the kids that's always a good
idea
or you can interpret that verse to be a
warning against sinful wrathful anger
and an admonition that we should not
stew in that kind of anger no matter if
it's dark outside or not
okay because the other part of that
verse is like well if
as long as i stu if i'm angry at 8 a.m
that means i got you know all day to be
angry and i'm good to go as long as it's
before sundown
no and you know you don't stew in the
anger that's the point that's true but
by no means does it entail that you have
to finish every argument before bedtime
in fact in the psalms we're told that
when we're angry we should quote reflect
in our hearts while on our beds
and be silent there you go
reflect and be silent is a much much
better thing to do when you're angry
in a marriage there's really no downside
because
you can always say what you wanted to
say at another time if you still
feel that it needs to be said you can
always live to fight another day
but you can't always take back the
things you do say
you can't always undo what you said when
you were angry and tired
and insisting that you both stay awake
so for all of those reasons this piece
of marriage advice
is most definitely cancelled and frankly
if you follow the advice
too much your marriage might be canceled
too eventually
so we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. a democrat operative tries to stop
ted cruz from exposing the crisis at the
border
joe biden pushes vaccine passports and a
rapper sells satanic sneakers
check it out on the michael knowles show